Чи будете ви пропонувати запровадити більше санкцій проти Росії
після того, що сталося у Керченській протоці?
Я бачу, що європейські партнери вже почали обговорювати цю тему -
чи треба запроваджувати додаткові санкції
у зв’язку з нещодавньою атакою Росії
на кораблі українських військово-морських сил.
Думаю: Європі варто уважно поглянути на впровадження вже існуючих санкцій.
Натепер діють жорсткі європейські санкції щодо Криму.
Але наскільки суворо вони застосовуються насправді?
Можна сказати, що концепція полягає в тому,
що ті, хто займаються бізнесом в Криму, не повинні мати змоги
займатися бізнесом у Євросоюзі. Думаю, варто поглянути свіжим поглядом
європейської перспективи, чи застосовуються санкції належним чином.
Наскільки реалістичним є запровадження санкцій щодо "Північного потоку-2"?
Як бачимо, внаслідок цього інциденту в Німеччині знову розгорілася дискусія,
чи треба продовжувати реалізацію "Північного потоку -2".
Думаю, що це є відображенням занепокоєння США з цього приводу,
яке висловлюється вже кілька років.
Занепокоєння з приводу того, що це суто геополітичний проект Росії -
постачати газ на Захід напряму
в обхід України та інших держав у Східній Європі.
При цьому збільшуючи тиск і розширюючи
прямий бізнес з партнерами у Західній Європі.
Як бачимо, причини призупинити цей проект є.
Крім того, виникають запитання з приводу відповідності антимонопольній політиці
Євросоюзу і газовим директивам ЄС. Там багато запитань.
Європейці починають порушувати це питання, це здорова дискусія.
І наша позиція завжди полягала в тому, що проект треба знову переглянути.
Російські ЗМІ повідомляють, що уряд США
проводить переговори з Україною про можливість розміщення військової бази
на українській території. Як ви це прокоментуєте?
Мені невідомо про якісь переговори на тему розміщення
постійної військової бази Сполучених Штатів в Україні.
Водночас, у нас є нормальне здорове оборонне співробітництво з Україною -
таке ж, як і з будь-якою іншою країною.
Ми допомагаємо тренувати, допомагаємо організаційно проводити
реформу Збройних Сил, щоб у них був сучасний потужний оборонний потенціал.
І маємо намір і надалі співпрацювати з ними у цій сфері.
Президент Порошенко застеріг, у доволі жорстких висловах,
про загрозу повномасштабної війни України з Росією.
Яка позиція США з цього приводу: чи справді є ризик серйозної ескалації?
Ми, звісно, не хочемо жодних великих військових конфліктів,
жодної війни з Росією. Це було б катастрофою для України, якби це сталося.
І  це було б невиправданим. Нам потрібна деескалація,
нам потрібно побачити сильну оборонну позицію, щоб стримувати
будь-яку подальшу агресію з російського боку.
І це може створити необхідні передумови для вирішення проблем,
яких натепер досі немає.
Президент Трамп планує зустріч з Путіним на саміті "великої двадцятки"
в Аргентині. Однак саміт виявився під питанням.
Що думають про це у Вашингтоні?
Це вирішувати президенту Трампу, як йому бути із зустрічами у найближчі дні.
Він заявив, що ми будемо про це думати,
і я думаю, ми почуємо відповідь президента.